eca ghislaine pierrât docteur en
communication politique ghislaine tira
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors à quoi assiste-t-on ce soir une
calinothérapie comme on a pu l'entendre
ou bien davantage un conseil de
discipline finalement alors d'abord le
terme calinothérapie est un terme b s'il
en politique il faut jamais perdre le
sens que tous les politiques sont là
pour porter l'histoire collective
l'histoire de la france donc on n'est
pas chez les bisounours
il s'agira souvenez-vous en septembre en
septembre il y avait eu quelques paroles
douces au départ et puis après il y
avait eu une remise à l'ordre des
troupes parlementaires
là c'est pas du tout la même chose parce
que on a des crises épisodique qui
révèle un vrai malaise et macron a bien
vu que l'histoire de l'excellent
parlementaire guy bricout avec le deuil
par le parental il ya eu bon le propos
comme quoi macron disait ou
parlementaire vous mentez d'humanité ce
qui n'était pas le cas il ya eu
l'histoire des retraites
donc on a quand même quelques
contentieux là ce soir ça va être un
dialogue ça va être des
questions-réponses ça va être une soirée
un peu particulière
mais il s'agit pas de calinothérapie
bien évidemment il va y avoir un vrai
dialogue selon vous parce que on se
souvient certains craignent justement
que
de voir le chef de l'état a finalement
parlé peut écouter comme certains
l'avaient constaté d'ailleurs lors des
grands débats
il va changer cette position cette
posture est arrivé c'est à espérer parce
que les grands débats c'était vraiment
le le le discours à l'infini donc il
était trop long qui était intelligent
qui était riche mais il n'y avait pas
cet échange là a priori d'après les
informations de différents
parlementaires
ça va être davantage question répond ça
va être davantage de dialogue et une une
explication
donc en fait je crois qu'il doit se
réconcilier avec les parlementaires
une explication vous lisiez qu'il
n'aurait pas pu se faire finalement loin
des caméras on le voit cette réunion est
largement médiatisée il ya une volonté
de l'elysée de médiatiser cette
rencontre ce rendez vous oui là on peut
discuter effectivement sur la
médiatisation de cette soirée mais bon
c'est inévitable donc autant embrayé le
pack de que d'empêcher les médias de
parler on parle de démocratie on parle
de vie parlementaire on parle de de
l'elysée de président de la république
est tout à fait normal que les médias
relatent l'événement est bien évidemment
à la sortie aura des micro-trottoirs
surtout des parlementaires sur ce qu'ils
auront pensé de cette soirée
alors justement des parlementaires vous
le vous le disiez dans un certain
malaise il ya eu tous ces couacs mais au
fond le malaise est il plus profond
qu'est ce qu'il révèle oui vous avez
raison de relever cet aspect le malaise
il est beaucoup plus profond parce que
l'assemblée nationale en fait
macron à un petit déficit
il est brillant il intelligent mais il
n'a pas c'est le seul président rendez
vous compte de la 5ème république qui
n'a pas d'expérience de député alors il
lui manque un peu cette culture
parlementaire et concrètement il devait
changer des choses
j'appelle ferment agissent car
contrairement à à mitterrand
contrairement à sarkozy contrairement à
hollande
il n'a jamais été députée donc il faut
qu'ils les pouces
culture parlementaire il faut qu'ils
aiment l'assemblée nationale et aimer
l'assemblée nationale pour moi c'est
déjà un gros gros pavé que vous appeliez
malaise profond de l'écu âgées l'écu
âgées c'est à un petit terminologie
baroque questions au gouvernement
exactement questions au gouvernement
et donc ces questions avant c'était le
mardi et le mercredi
ça faisait vivre l'institution c'est
c'était une heure de 15 heures à 16
heures et après les parlementaires a les
doigts vers les médias voyaient les
ministres et la maison vivait cette
assemblée nationale c c'est un
formidable exemple de démocratie dans le
monde entier et bien évidemment que les
quais l'écu âgées question gouvernements
doivent est de nouveau le mardi et le
mercredi tous les partis problème ça se
passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est le mardi de 15 heures
à 17 heures c'est insupportable pour
tout le monde et tout le monde dit mais
c'est pas possible
bon c'est ces trolls c'est trop c'est
trop condensé on ne fait pas un bon
boulot il faut revenir à la formule
d'avant - le dialogue plus de dialogue
c'est ça l'assemblée nationale
finalement aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale les gens s'en sont malheureux
ils ont ils ont besoin de de proximité
et puis il ya aussi les municipales les
municipales il ya des parlementaires qui
n'ont pas démérité et tout d'un coup paf
on leur impose quelqu'un pour briguer
une mairie qui voulait briguer donc il
ya beaucoup de déçus il ya beaucoup de
gens au delà du dialogue comme vous
disiez au delà du dialogue
il ya aussi bondée dévions qui
comprennent pas pourquoi
n'ayant pas démérité quand tout d'un
coup ils ne peuvent pas briguer une
mairie comme il l'aurait souhaité tous
ces couacs que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est quoi c'est ça relève d'un
manque d'expérience chez les députés de
la république en marche vous êtes encore
autre chose
non moi je trouve ça bien sûr qu'au
départ il soit arrivé c'était les bleus
qui débarquait mais beaucoup ont appris
beaucoup sont très méritants passionnés
dont il ya quelques hurluberlus que tout
le monde a déjà repéré sans les citer
mais mais sinon bon il faut il faut un
travail
et ils sont très assidus ils sont très
appliqués
donc bon après tout on est loin quand
même de la période initiale où il y
avait d une tous les quatre matins de
députés qui avaient fait des choses un
petit peu extravagante la non les gens
sont appliquées bosse vraiment il faut
revaloriser le politique en france il
faut revaloriser le travail
parlementaire et macro seraient bien
inspirés des mets l'assemblée nationale
de mieux faire le nia souvenez vous au
lendemain hollande a reçu les
parlementaires qu'une fois mais sarkozy
recevait les parlementaires sans arrêt
maquereau a reçu seulement trois ou
quatre fois donc c'est pas beaucoup
il reçoit par commission régulièrement
mais c'est pas suffisant
la politique c'est extrêmement affectif
donc il faut la faire vivre ce soir
resserrer le lien avec ces
parlementaires oui à pouvoir le réaliser
et emmanuel macron selon vous les
parlementaires sont d'après ce que j'ai
entendu assez content d'aller à l'elysée
là on a pas on n'a pas le plan de coupes
turquie qui a qui arrivent à l'elysée
mais bon je pense que d'après ce que
j'ai compris il ya beaucoup de
parlementaires donc y en a pas 15 qui
vont y aller
bon sur la majorité c'est-à-dire il ya
trois cent douze parlementaires il y en
a 14 de parts en est là sur les 312 ça
sera très intéressant de voir justement
le nombre des parlementaires qui s'est
rendu à l'invitation
vous parliez effectivement de ses 300
députés qui ont été invités il y en a
plus d'une dizaine qui sont partis
depuis l'élection du président macron
elle encore qu'est ce que ça veut dire
finalement ça veut dire que les liens se
sont trop distendu il faut
impérativement que macron renou face de
la proximité
je fasse jouer là confiante et là à la
veille des municipales qui a priori vont
être assez douloureuse pour un marche
il est très important qui rebooster ses
troupes killer qui leur redonne le champ
ce qui est un président ça donne des
perspectives
il doit expliquer où on va sur la
réforme des retraites
peut-être que ça serait bien qu'elle
soit incarnée aussi par le par le
président les les
là on va avoir un débat à partir du 17
bon ça va être assez à s'est enflammé à
l'assemblée nationale et ça va être
assez assez compliqué à c'est assez
douloureux aussi liens que ce statut est
l'art la réforme des retraites
c'est compliqué au niveau du financement
et vous avez vu que le conseil d'état a
dit votre qu'il est mal ficelé et
comment on le finance donc ça
déstabilise quand même les députés
en tout cas ce que cette cette soirée de
ce soir cette rencontre de ce soir peut
finalement être le signe d'un d'un
second souffle pour le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro cette soirée ce soir
j'ai pas compris votre propre est est ce
que ça peut être le départ d'un nouveau
souffle pour emmanuel double barre oui
pour une infection qui amènerait à
ajoutera des décisions la réforme des
retraites
elle est fondamentale il faut pas que ça
parte dans un cul-de-sac
bon on voit que la france a soumise à
multiplier les amendements et veut
absolument qu'on arrête franchement
c'est pas possible tout le monde a
compris en france que l'on vit tous plus
vieux et que bon set entre la réforme à
60 ans et les 35 heures il ya de quoi
faire donc je crois que tout le monde
doit peut comprendre
encore faut-il faire une pédagogie
intelligente que étant donné que l'âge
l'individu va en progression il faut
engager une réforme
par contre bon il ya peut-être des
points qu'ils soient améliorées il doit
absolument réussir cette réforme des
retraites alors c'est pas seulement la
soirée de ce soir qui va donner un
second souffle
c'est plus cette réforme des retraites
qu'il doit absolument réussir ils
doivent se mettre les moyens
et attention il ya des gens qui les
interpellent mais les parlementaires
ils sont là pour contrôler l'action du
gouvernement ils sont dans leur rôle
donc il faut pas dire ya les bons il ya
les gentils ya les méchants c'est pas ça
ils sont dans leur rôle
donc cette réforme elle doit revoir le
jour parce qu'elle est nécessaire et on
doit l'améliorer donc il faut être plus
dans l'état d'esprit où emmanuel macron
et ses troupes doivent améliorer cette
réforme doit coûte que coûte
voir le jour et après bon effectivement
s'il passe le cap parce que n'oublions
pas que les municipales ça va être quand
même un petit gars d'à du conquet donc
du coup après il y aura un bonbon un
second souffle
vous avez raison de dire que bon on est
à un cahier rouge politique
merci beaucoup ghislaine pierrât d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en communication
politique